l'inflation reste écrasante et
s'accélère pour ses calculs de juin
l'insee fixe à 5 8% sur un an la hausse
des prix elle était de 5,2 en mai de 4 8
en avril et de quatre ans et demi en
mars dans ce contexte une aide
alimentaire d'urgence de 100 euros sera
versée à neuf millions de français à la
rentrée le gouvernement l'a confirmé
hier soir 100 euros auxquels s'ajoutent
50 euros par enfant honey 2 toujours de
l'aide toujours de l'ailé moi j'aime
bricoler des les jeunes qui travaillent
d'abord et vous verrez que peut-être à
ceux qui pensaient pas sur mes traits au
travail connaît des légères et comme
l'intervenant la colère dans tout ce qui
n'est pas l'école qui payent pas les
cochons se paye pas la cavité ils payent
rien et bien comme ça au moins ça
mettrait les gens au travail parce que
les jeunes qui veulent rien perdre ou
s'en viennent ça c'est sûr moi je croise
les naseaux alex et à l'accès
[Musique]
aux
accents
3,4
[Musique]
et moi j'ai un papa très clairement qui
m'a dit la vie kevin l'aide machin tout
ça je dis ouais bon bah après avoir etc
qu'est-ce qui me dit ah ben moi que ça
c'est clair concept encore en vacances
avec
j'en peux plus de cette émission je m'en
veux tu t'en vas ouais
non mais non excusez-moi kevin mais bien
sûr raconté il s'agit de mon voile
arraché 50 euros je pense tout bas sens
c'est l'heure de la photo cochonou et
oui c'est manu le chypre avec
sans aucun trucage de serge qu'un filtre
avec la deudeuche cochaux douce sur le
tour de france ah non non non north
wayne dwayne wade même on sait bien ce
qui est arrivé à un salarié de
l'entreprise contorsions industriel déry
mantos un grand groupe de fabrication de
charcuterie au chili lorsqu il vérifie
ses comptes le mois dernier l'employé se
rend compte que son salaire est bien
différent au lieu d 520 euros habituels
il a été payé plus de 172 milles euros
soit près de 300 fois son salaire et
c'est là qu'intervient le dilemme que
faire marinière son patron et donc
rendre l'argent ou bien tenter d'en
profiter et bien notre ami a semble-t-il
hésité parce que le lendemain il est
venu au boulot il a prévenu son
employeur qui a constaté l'erreur et lui
ordonne immédiatement de rendre le trop
perçu
le salarié s'engage d'abord à rembourser
puis disparaît laissant derrière lui une
lettre de démission
[Musique]
mais aussi d'étendre mon portable
parce que dieu ne te laisse pas son
portable
il n'y a pas de connexion n'est pas dans
ta net pour lui
il fait simple rencontre comme kevin et
mélanie ils ont fait rencontrer
le pic de contamination va être
probablement plus tôt pour fin juillet
la déclaration ce matin sur rtl de jean
françois delfraissy qui confirme ce que
nous vous disions hier dans le 12 45 le
président du conseil scientifique ajoute
que le nouveau variant le béa 5 sera
alors majoritaire il prévoit un deuxième
pic en octobre ou en novembre
pour l'instant le gouvernement va voir
croisons les doigts paris sur la
responsabilité de chacun et mal à bord
n'a diffusé que mettre le masque sur des
lieux de promiscuité voile à amatan et
delfraissy ce matin j'ai oublié mon
mouton des frais si tu sais que j'ai
acheter un mouton sur l'amazone à la
fois je vous le ramenez pas sur la chine
peluche moutons parce que ici mais tu
crois que tu crois ce qu'est ce que tu
entres tel prix des laitues pommées tué
6 2 par exemple il veut pas le blé ont
valsé prodigue l'obligation du masque
bête à tête zébré l'hérault oui
est ce que ça représente des nuages
très abstrait ah ouais jab stress
prendre après l'heure c'est subjectif
donc un malentendu
les gars n'ont plasticien italien il est
quand même parvenu c'est un coup de
maître à vendre une oeuvre invisible est
le seul à pouvoir voir dans sa propreté
c'est bien quand même quinze mille euros
pour une oeuvre que tu vois toi même
dans sa propre tête tu as tu me dises et
des nuages j'ai envie de garder comme au
musée de m'asseoir sur un banc il nous
dira bon coup j'ai raté quelque chose ou
ou cd génie mais vous êtes allés au
maïdo régulièrement fois que les deux
fois quand les enfants effectif que j'y
vais régulièrement je crois toujours la
même chose je prends un hamburger je
prends une frite moyenne et un sound et
nature on est content de l'apprendre
raciale avec la france est un des
pygmées plus de mac do vous êtes super
étrange ce soir alors moi j'ai une vraie
question pas parfois on fait pour le
matin et on va direct sur la deux
si on met le gps
comme je ne relis peau ces systèmes
innovants des ballons mais de l'eau
là on est d'être
mi-2009 mine aux mineurs ouais je sais
qu'il travaille à la mine
s'est séparé ménez en 14-18 première
guerre mondiale en 1916 bataille de
verdun 1910 et révolution douce 11
novembre 18 ses larmes les camps sont
cause mais on va me remercierez
parce que voilà un
nom sur tes seins seigner a fermement
rejeté comme au
plus haut point
merci en tout cas veut dire on reste
sans conteste en temps réel des cas
quelque chose tu m'appelles je vous
remercie
[Musique]